Professor Amy
Hungerford: Now,
what's coming up?
As I mentioned last week,
on Wednesday I'm going to give
my censorship lecture,
and in preparation for that I
would like you to go to a local
bookstore, any one,
and just observe how it's laid
out, what you see,
what your attention is called
to,
what your attention is not
called to, and here's a
difficult question:
What isn't there?
Think about that,
and I'll talk a little bit
about what isn't there on
Wednesday.
Also, in order to keep up,
please try to read at least to
page 202--that's the next
chapter division in The Human
Stain--so that you're on
track to finish it--it's 361
pages--for next Monday.
And so, next Monday,
a week from today,
I will give my second lecture
on The Human Stain.
And I will talk about
The Human Stain a little
bit on Wednesday,
because some of what I have to
say about censorship does
pertain,
so that's what's coming up.
I hope you all thought
about the Identity Plot as you
read this novel.
It's hard not to.
When I gave that lecture,
I suggested that when a genre
gains a certain credence,
a certain widespread use in the
culture, it requires more and
more innovations on it to make a
fresh story out of it.
It also gets us to the point
where that set of conventions is
available to writers in a new
way, to be transcended in a new
way.
So, one thing that I want to
ask about this novel is,
does it transcend the genre?
Does it do more than provide
the certain dramas and
satisfactions that we come to
expect from a novel about
identity?
In this sense,
because it is so deeply
embedded in those kinds of
narratives, Roth is taking a
kind of risk here.
He's playing it safe because he
knows that this is a topic of
interest, but he's taking a risk
as an artist because he's
working in very well-trodden
territory.
I suggested that,
also, when a genre reaches a
certain point of saturation,
writers tend to change the
subject.
I didn't say this when we
talked about Blood
Meridian, but I think
in part Blood Meridian is
that kind of change of subject.
So, this returns to the genre,
and we want to ask what it's
doing with the genre.
Before I go in to my meditation
on that question today,
I just want to call your
attention to another element
that does relate back to
Blood Meridian,
and that's its status
as a historical novel.
This novel places itself with
certain kinds of historical
markers at the very opening.
It was the summer of 1998,
the summer of the Monica
Lewinsky affair,
the summer when Viagra takes
off in the marketplace.
Those are very contemporary
historical markers.
Now, think back to the way
Blood Meridian opens with
its historical markers.
Do you remember this line?
It's the father talking about
the kid's birth.
He says, "Night of your birth,
'33.
God, how the stars did fall."
I think I've got that correct.
What he's talking about is the
Leonid meteor showers in 1833
that mark the night of the kid's
birth.
For all that McCarthy is
interested in--and mining--the
historical detail of the 1830s,
'40s, '50s, that novel favors
historical markers that seem
like cosmic markers of time.
So, contrast the stars falling
in, yes, a historically specific
meteor shower,
but nevertheless in something
that looks like a cosmic
communication of meaning.
Contrast that with the
relatively mundane,
debased historical markers that
Roth chooses,
Viagra, the Monica Lewinsky
scandal.
You want to ask yourself,
what kind of history is each
writer invoking?
I want to suggest to you
that if you press on the markers
that Roth chooses,
you will find something more
than trivia, more than
contemporary trivia,
that Roth has in his sights an
equally universal,
trans-historical kind of truth
in this novel,
that's brought up by those
little details of history.
And that trans-historical
history is the history of
desire, of which both those
things are indicative.
I will say a lot more about
desire and its relationship to
the history of literature and to
writing in this novel in my
Monday lecture,
but as you go on I would like
you to think about how history
functions as a set of contexts
for the story that Roth tells
you.
Now I want to talk about
identity.
So, does this novel conform to
the form of the Identity Plot?
There are certain ways I think
it does, and it does so in a
very explicit way.
Remember how I mentioned that
tension in the Identity Plot is
produced by the individual's
relationship to the group and
the way that's vexed.
It isn't a very exciting
Identity Plot if the protagonist
just discovers that he or she is
whatever categorizable identity
and says, "Oh,
good.
I'll be that," and then goes on.
The tension comes from feeling
that either such an
identification would be
coercion, or that it comes with
all kinds of attendant
suffering.
There are all kinds of tensions
that are produced in making that
not an easy identification,
and you can see that very
explicitly in this novel on page
108--106,108--when Coleman talks
about being at Howard
University,
and along with that,
the experience of being called
a "nigger" for the first time.
This is on the top of 106:
Especially when he began
to think that there was
something of the nigger about
him,
even to the kids in the dorm
who had all sorts of new
clothes, and money in their
pockets,
and in the summertime didn't
hang around the hot streets at
home, but went to camp,
and not Boy Scout camp out in
the Jersey sticks,
but fancy places where they
rode horses and played tennis
and acted in plays.
What the hell was a cotillion?
Where was Highland Beach?
What were these kids talking
about?
He was among the very lightest
of the light-skinned in his
freshman class,
lighter even than his
tea-colored roommate,
but he could have been the
blackest, most benighted field
hand, for all they knew that he
didn't.
He hated Howard from the day he
arrived.
Within a week he hated
Washington, and so in early
October, when his father dropped
dead serving dinner on the
Pennsylvania Railroad dining car
that was pulling out of 30^(th)
Street station in Philadelphia
for Wilmington,
and Coleman went home for the
funeral, he told his mother he
was finished with that
college.
Right there in that sentence,
in this little set of scenes
about Howard and his experience
in D.C.,
you see him at first being
asked by his family to identify
with a certain version of the
black middle class,
and then finding he is revolted
by his own difference from that
middle class.
He feels like a black field
hand, the darkest of the dark
field hand, "for all they knew
that he didn't," and on 108 we
get it in very abstract terms.
"You finally leave home,
the Ur of we,
and you find another we,
another place that's just like
that,
the substitute for
that."The problem of the
Identity Plot is the problem of
the "I" and the "we."
Here is Coleman laying out
exactly how he feels about that,
and so what he's going to favor
there,
again on 108,
is the raw "I," all the
subtlety of being Silky Silk.
So there you have encapsulated,
in a very short amount of
prose, a major form--narrative
form, narrative dynamic--of the
Identity Plot as a genre.
On 144, you get another version
of that, slightly more
personalized to his family.
This is another version of
identity and what Coleman thinks
about it.
This is after we get the
history of Coleman's family,
his ancestors,
and we're told that he is not
the first to pass as white or to
disappear from the black family
in to which he was born:
"Lost himself to all his
people" was another way they,
the family, put it.
Ancestor worship,
that's how Coleman put it.
Honoring the past was one thing.
The idolatry that is ancestor
worship was something else.
The hell with that
imprisonment.
So, this version of identity on
144, this vision of it,
is identity as ancestor worship
and imprisonment in that family,
imprisonment in that way of
thinking, a radical un-freedom.
So, this is one version of
identity, radically individual,
rising out of the difference
that you feel from the various
"we" groups you are asked to
join.
But there are other versions of
identity that are imagined here,
and they track pretty clearly
with scholarly ways of thinking
about identity at this same
time.
So, in one sense identity
is this radical individual
humanist version that I've been
tracing in the last few minutes.
Another is that identity is a
constantly changing performance,
and we get that too in Coleman.
You see it, again,
right in the section about
Howard on 109,
and I want you to note the
words that Roth chooses here,
109 in the middle:
"He could play his skin however
he wanted, color himself just as
he chose."
"Play his skin any way he
wanted."
Now, remember that his father
is a great devotee of
Shakespeare and tries to
communicate to his children,
not only through their
Shakespearian middle names,
but through every verbal
interaction he has with them,
that the grandeur of the
English language will somehow
fill them and make them who they
are,
that this is the source of
their dignity and their power.
He takes that lesson and
transforms it.
It's about playing on the model
of drama, but it's about playing
color, and this is an artist's
vocation, "color himself just as
he chose."
He's like a painter,
in this sense,
so this is identity as
performance.
There are many instances of
this.
On page 115,116,
there is just a little
description of Steena's dance
for Coleman.
I'm going to just read a little
bit of it.
All at once,
with no prompting from him,
seemingly prompted only by
Eldridge's trumpet,
she began what Coleman liked to
describe as the single most
slithery dance ever performed by
a Fergus Falls girl after a
little more than a year in New
York City.
She could have raised Gershwin
himself from the grave with that
dance, and with the way she sang
the song,
prompted by a colored trumpet
player playing it like a black
torch song.
There to see,
plain as day,
was all the power of her
whiteness, that big,
white thing.
"Someday he'll come along,
the man I love,
and he'll be big and strong,
the man I love."
The language was ordinary
enough to have been lifted from
the most innocent first-grade
primer,
but when the record was over,
Steena put her hands up to hide
her face, half meaning,
half pretending,
to cover her shame.
The history of jazz that's
concentrated in to that tiny,
little passage has been
unpacked by a critic by the name
of Jonathan Freedman.
He does a whole history,
which I can't produce here,
of how Artie Shaw and various
players played Gershwin,
and used black musicians in
their ensembles,
and how this very dance,
when Steena,
here, we're told,
in a way, inhabits most fully
her whiteness,
she does that by performing to
a music that is radically
hybrid,
black and Jewish.
So, Freedman argues that in
this passage we get identity as
a vision of absolute fluidity,
absolute performance and
fluidity, and that the whole
history of American jazz stands
behind that imagined state.
It's the very difference
between the hybrid music and the
pure whiteness of Steena's body
that creates what's so
provocative to Coleman,
the spectacle of whiteness in
the context of hybridity.
The father's obsession with
the English language,
though, has taught Coleman to
categorize relentlessly.
Do you remember this little
detail?
This is on page 93 when Coleman
is describing or we're having
described to us exactly how
Coleman's father taught them to
speak.
This is on 93.
Growing up they never
said, "See the bow-wow."
They didn't even say,
"See the doggie."
They said, "See the Doberman.
See the beagle.
See the terrier."
They learned things had
classifications.
They learned the power of
naming precisely."
The father, for all that he is
imbuing them with the most elite
version of a white literary
tradition,
Shakespeare,
he is also teaching them
relentlessly to see
classification and categorizing.
In Coleman this comes to mean
something quite different,
and you see it in this funny,
little passing moment on 107,
the very top of the page.
This is talking about his
father's cherished volume of
Shakespeare's plays,
the oversized book with the
floppy leather binding that,
when Coleman was a small boy,
always reminded him of a cocker
spaniel.
The son felt his father's
majesty as never before,
the grandeur of both his rise
and his fall,
the grandeur that as a college
freshman away for barely a
month.--[And then it quotes from
Shakespeare.]
The cocker spaniel: Why?
Why choose that as what the
little boy thinks of when he
looks at that floppy volume?
It's a moment when being
trained to classify and to
categorize causes him to see the
source of that linguistic
precision,
the book of Shakespeare,
in very demeaning terms,
or reductive terms or--I'm not
getting quite the precise word I
want--in deflating terms.
So that, instead of grandeur,
the book of Shakespeare becomes
the source for the names of
dogs.
And the way the child's
imagination blends grandeur and
the ordinary,
I think,
gives us Coleman,
who can imagine the details of
everyday life,
the life he lives,
as a grand play.
Doc Chizner furthers this
transformation of the father's
lesson in this very crucial
passage,
that I'm going to talk more
about later, when Coleman passes
as white or Jewish for the first
time.
And that's when he's boxing for
the pit coach:
"If nothing comes up,"
Doc said [this is the bottom of
98]
"you don't bring it up.
You're neither one thing or the
other.
You're Silky Silk.
That's enough.
That's the deal."
"You're neither one thing or
the other.
You're Silky Silk."
This takes the question of
categorization--are you colored?
Are you not?--it negates it:
you're neither one thing nor
another, but then reinstates it
in a different mode:
you're Silky Silk.
Make up a new category for
yourself.
So, Doc Chizner takes that
transgressing use of precision
that we see in the cocker
spaniel metaphor in the child's
imagination,
and he shows Coleman how to
apply that to living race in
America, living his race in
America.
You are Silky Silk.
You're not a race.
You're a proper name,
the irreducible singularity of
a person.
There is a third way of
thinking about race,
and that, of course,
is as biology.
That, too, is present in this
novel.
The body is relentlessly
present, and I hope that you
picked up on that.
It's not hard to pick up on it.
The very matter and specificity
of the body is everywhere in
this novel, and so I want to
look back at 21 and 22.
This is in that wonderful scene
when Coleman dances with Nathan.
So, we get a whole description
of Coleman's body and what it is
that Nathan sees in it,
suddenly, now that he's
shirtless on this hot summer
night, and also now that he is
no longer talking about the
"spooks" business.
This is 21.
On display were the
shoulders, arms and chest of a
smallish man still trim and
attractive,
a belly no longer flat,
to be sure, but nothing that
had gotten seriously out of
hand,
altogether the physique of
someone who had seemed to have
been a cunning and wily
competitor at sports rather than
an overpowering one.
And all of this had previously
been concealed from me,
because he was always shirted,
and also because of his having
been so drastically consumed by
his rage.
What you see there is the
revelation of certain things we
will find out to be true about
Coleman,
that he was a cunning and wily
competitor rather than an
overpowering one,
that he is still fit and
virile,
that he has himself in hand,
nothing that had gotten out of
hand, seriously out of hand.
Coleman very much still has
himself in hand.
He is still the maker of
himself, the presenter of
himself to the world in a
deliberate way.
But then we go on,
and there are some things that
we see that perhaps tell us
something different.
Rather than the body revealing
the truth about Coleman--
certain kinds of truth,
not a racial truth,
other kinds of truth--we see
marks on his body that don't
produce that knowledge.
Also previously concealed
was the small,
Popeye-ish blue tattoo situated
at the top of his right arm just
at the shoulder joining,
the words "U.S.
Navy" inscribed between the
hooklike arms of a shadowy
little anchor and running along
the hypotenuse of the deltoid
muscle,
a tiny symbol if one were
needed of all the million
circumstances of the other
fellow's life,
of that blizzard of details
that constitute the confusion of
a human biography,
a tiny symbol to remind me why
our understanding of people must
always be, at best,
slightly wrong.
What's revealed when Coleman is
shirtless is the very sign that
he cannot be known in any kind
of complete way.
It's the mark of a history on
his body, that he was in the
navy, a history we'll learn a
little bit about,
but not a lot,
but for Nathan it is the mark
of an irreducible difference
between persons,
that always there are details
that are not accessible,
circumstances of the other
fellow's life.
In this moment Nathan
recognizes Coleman as a cipher,
a sign that can be projected
upon with meanings of his own.
I would suggest to you that we
don't see the full flowering of
this until quite a bit later in
the novel,
but I think this is the first
moment where,
in Coleman revealing his body,
he suggests to Nathan the
possibilities of that body as a
sign.
So, he is no longer,
in this moment,
entirely "in hand" anymore.
So, if his physique hasn't
gotten out of hand,
his circulation as a sign
certainly has.
In this case,
he has now become a blank
canvas for Nathan.
Certainly, up until this moment
at the beginning of the novel,
what's most on the surface of
the plot is how he has become
the victim of rumor,
how his self-presentation got
completely out of hand,
taken over by other people's
erroneous readings of his words.
So, if the body seems to be in
his control, himself as a
signifier is not.
Here Nathan is invited into it,
but in a very different way
than the rumormongers who
surround him at Athena College
and in the town.
So, the body is not going to be
a place of revelation.
Speech, as I've noted,
is a problematic moment of
revelation, but it can be that.
And on 81,82,
we see an example of that when
his speech formally in the novel
touches off what will be some of
the most important revelatory
passages in the novel.
And this is when Nelson Primus,
having berated Coleman and
advised him in his clever,
authoritative,
arrogant way not to pursue
anything against Lester Farley
or Delphine Roux,
has offended him and enraged
him so much as to become the
target of Coleman's rage.
Coleman said,
"I never again want to hear
that self-admiring voice of
yours or see your smug,
fucking, lily-white face," and
the question becomes why--and we
see Nelson ask it the next
page--why "white,"
why does "lily-white" become
the insult that he hurls at
Nelson?
And formally,
even though there's a little
bit of an interlude here about
Athena College and Coleman's
rage,
this is the moment when we
launch into the tale of
Coleman's childhood,
and we learn for the first time
what kind of family he comes
from,
and what the history of his
passing has been,
how he made that decision to
abandon his family of birth.
So, speech can be
revealing, but only in those
moments when it is out of
Coleman's control.
Here, in this moment,
"lily-white" is inspired by his
rage.
He is out of control,
in that sense,
and of course,
"lily white" is the term his
brother,
Walt, applies to him in a
similar moment of anger,
after Walt discovers that he
has told his mother that he is
essentially estranging himself
permanently from the family in
order to marry Iris.
Walt says, "Don't ever show
your lily-white face here
again."
So, he's reproducing Walt's
language, and,
from that, it indicates to
Nelson Primus and for us,
in the unfolding of the novel,
that there is a mystery here to
be told.
And then we get the telling of
that mystery.
So, from that little word,
all of this unfurls,
and I would just note,
just in passing,
that this is quite a contrast
to Delphine Roux.
On 38 and 39,
you can look at:
Coleman is very surprised that
she has made no effort to hide
the identifying marks of her own
handwriting.
Delphine Roux--though her name
suggests the Delphic,
the oracular,
the mysterious,
the secret--Delphine is someone
who cannot conceal herself.
The very material of her
language, of her writing,
of her letters,
puts her identity on the page
to be read,
and it seems as if she hasn't
even tried to conceal it.
So, Delphine's lack of depth,
her lack of complexity as a
character, her basic
despicableness is summed up in
that inability to conceal
herself,
whereas Coleman only reveals
himself in moments when he is
unguarded, or when he has
become,
not a person in control of his
own representation of himself,
but rather a sign at large
among other representers
(Nathan,
Delphine, other people).
Secrecy,
then, is at the very heart of
what identity means in this
novel, and now I want to get to
this crucial passage on page
100.
For me, this is where we learn
really what identity means in
this novel.
So, he says he wants to be in
this fight with--in front of the
Pitt coach--with Ray Robinson.
It wasn't just that [This
is on 99.]
It wasn't just that Coleman
weighed some seven pounds more
than when he'd boxed on the
amateur card at the Knights of
Pythias.
It was that something he could
not even name made him want to
be more damaging than he'd ever
dared before,
to do something more that day
than merely win.
Was it because the pit coach
didn't know he was colored?
Could it be because who he
really was was entirely his
secret?
He did love secrets,
the secret of nobody's knowing
what was going on in your head,
thinking whatever you wanted to
think, with no way of anybody's
knowing.
All the other kids were always
blabbing about themselves,
but that wasn't where the power
was, or the pleasure either.
The power and the pleasure were
to be found in the opposite,
in being counter-confessional
in the same way you were a
counter-puncher,
and he knew that with nobody
having to tell him and without
his having to think about it.
That's why he liked shadow
boxing and hitting the heavy
bag, for the secrecy of
it.
And I'm going to skip down a
little bit.
He talks about concentrating,
and how the secrecy is produced
by the concentration,
or is related to the
concentration on the one thing
that you're doing.
Whatever is to be
mastered, he becomes that thing.
He could do that in biology,
and he could do it in the dash,
and he could do it in boxing,
and not only did nothing
external make any difference;
neither did anything
internal.
That little example right
there: He could do it in
biology, on a biology exam he
could focus exclusively on that
thing,
become that thing,
in the dash,
in boxing in the ring,
but why choose that example?
Why not mathematics?
Why not chemistry?
Well, here again,
it's Roth's craft coming
through.
Roth chose that because what
Coleman does is precisely to
overcome biology.
It's the biology of who his
parents are, of who their
parents are.
That biology,
the biology of American race,
is what he takes hold of and
transforms.
It becomes his secret.
Biology becomes his secret,
not as an academic subject,
but as a lived experience.
Boxing is the sport of
concealment for him,
thinking ahead,
observing his opponent,
watching how slow the punch is:
All the answers that you
came up with in the ring,
you kept to yourself,
and when you let the secret
out, you let it out through
everything but your mouth.
For all Coleman's training in
the English language from his
father, his mode of revelation,
his mode of communication,
is not verbal.
It is somehow physical,
as a physical performance,
as a damaging physical
performance.
That term
"counter-confessional,"
being--the pleasure and the
power were in--being
counter-confessional in the same
way you were a counter-puncher,
in not telling--this is quite a
remarkable term for Roth to use.
The history of Roth's writing
from the very first story
collection, Goodbye,
Columbus published in 1960,
through the many,
many novels in the next five
decades,
that trajectory,
which I'm going to talk a
little bit about on Wednesday,
is defined by the confessional
quality of many of these
works.So,
Roth is widely known for
drawing on his own life in his
fiction, and for making Nathan
Zuckerman track his biography in
significant ways.
And, in this novel,
it happens to be true that
Philip Roth went through
prostate cancer surgery and now
lives up in the Berkshires and
has been very secluded up there
and very productive writing
novels in the last ten years.
So, in this novel already,
anybody who knows even those
basic facts knows that Roth
himself as a writer is
confessional,
in some sense of the word.
One question we might want to
ask is: is he
counter-confessional the way
that Coleman is,
the way that you can be a
counter-puncher,
and what would it mean to be
that?
Why does it matter?
In fact, does it matter?
And then, why does it matter,
if it does, that his novels
track his life?
This is a long-term question
for anyone who thinks about
Roth's writing,
and I will get more to it in my
second lecture on The Human
Stain next Monday,
but it's something to think
about.
But let me pause,
again, on that rhetorical
question.
"Was it because the pit coach
didn't know he was colored?
Could it be because who he
really was was entirely his
secret?"
There are two ways of reading
that last question.
"Who he really was was
entirely his secret."
If we read that,
"who he really was" as a
colored guy from East Orange,
then we'll see it as that being
his secret.
But you can read it,
you can parse that grammar,
a different way.
"Who he really was was his
secret."
Could it be because who he
really was was "his secret,"
secrecy as the essence of
identity?
It doesn't matter what's in
that hidden box.
It doesn't mean that we have to
fill it in.
It doesn't mean,
even, that it can be known.
And you think back to the way
the anchor on his arm,
the tattoo on his arm,
reminds Nathan of how little
you can ever know about the
other fellow.
The very fact of the person's
other-ness to you means that
there is always something
fundamentally hidden about them,
and that arises from the simple
difference between one
consciousness and another.
This returns the meditation
on identity to a universalist,
humanist version of what
identity would be.
It's simply private
consciousness.
Private consciousness is what
defines us as persons,
and then, radiating out from
that,
all the things that one can do
with a private consciousness,
which then encompasses these
other modes of identifying that
the novel rehearses,
and then critiques or sometimes
endorses, plays with,
jumbles, juggles.
We have a private consciousness.
You can decide to decide.
This is something that Coleman
does on a number of occasions,
and it's a phrase that Roth
repeats when he's deciding to
decide to be done with the
spooks business,
deciding to decide not to be
worried about Lester Farley.
You have the power to form your
self-presentation.
You have the power to make your
identity an artistic
performance.
That's what private
consciousness does for you,
but it does a couple other
things,
too, and I want to track those,
or suggest them just briefly
before I end today,
in one sense by following the
theme of difference,
and in the other sense by
following the word "secrecy" in
the novel.
First, on the question of
pure difference,
on 47, in that wonderful scene
of Faunia with the cows,
this is Nathan reflecting on
the desire that he sees enacted
there.
And again, remember,
Coleman is not primarily a man
of words, but a man of being,
and he has just stood in
silence with Nathan watching
Faunia milk the cows.
It was enough to be able
to conduct themselves like two
people who had nothing
whatsoever in common,
all the while remembering how
they could distill to an
orgasmic essence everything
about them that was
irreconcilable,
the human discrepancies that
produced all the power.
It was enough to feel the
thrill of leading a double
life.
And what this passage,
the sentences above,
emphasize, is that Faunia is a
woman of thirty-four,
a "wordless illiterate," and
that Coleman is a man replete
with the vocabularies of two
ancient tongues,
as well as his own native
tongue.
So, the very difference between
them, this time limned in terms
of education and language,
vocabulary, literacy,
here it's that difference that
is invoked as the engine of
desire.
So, if desire is always that
looking towards the other thing,
the thing that you are not,
the thing that you do not have,
the thing that is absent from
you: that's the definition of
desire.
You can't have desire if you
already have the thing.
Desire is that force that's
always reaching toward something
that is separate from you.
Difference between human beings
is just that,
in this scene,
just the engine of desire.
So, here,
for all the meditations on
race, the social construction of
race, race as performance,
race as essence,
race as biology,
race as secret,
it's secret that gets to that
over-arching concern with desire
in the novel.
And this is a moment where I
think Roth is transcending the
genre.
He's taking the dramas of the
Identity Plot,
and he's driving them to an
extreme and pushing them over in
to another subject matter.
So, in this sense,
identity as secrecy pushes us
over in to the subject matter of
desire and mortality,
which is at the heart of Roth's
writing from beginning to end.
Now, I will not say that
identity is not also a subject
matter he's working with from
beginning to end of his career.
That's definitely true,
and I'll say more about that on
Wednesday when I talk about the
shape of his career.
But especially as Roth moves
later in his career these
questions of desire and
mortality take the upper hand.
Now, the last thing I want
to do, just very quickly,
is point to page 44,
another use of that word
"secret," the very top of the
page.
The secret to living in
the rush of the world with a
minimum of pain is to get as
many people as possible to
string along with your
delusions.
The trick of living alone up
here, away from all agitating
entanglements,
allurements,
and expectations,
apart especially from one's own
intensity, is to organize the
silence,
to think of its mountaintop
plenitude as capital,
silence as wealth exponentially
increasing,
the encircling silence as your
chosen source of advantage and
your only intimate.
The trick is to find
sustenance, this is quoting
Hawthorne again,
the communications of a
solitary mind with itself.
The secret is to find
sustenance in people like
Hawthorne, in the wisdom of the
brilliant deceased.
Now, one question I,
myself, as a reader have
struggled with about this novel
is whether Roth imagines that
Nathan's state,
when he describes it that way,
is a false one or a weak one,
one to be rejected.
Is it a withdrawal from life?
I think that last sentence,
"The secret is to find
sustenance in people like
Hawthorne," gives us the answer
that I'm content with.
And that is:
yes, it's a withdrawal from
life if you don't understand
Hawthorne as a person,
as someone with whom you can
become entangled.
It's the very act of thinking
of a literary forebear as a
person rather than a text that
allows this to be a productive
state,
one that Nathan will be drawn
out of by Coleman,
but yet one that the novel does
not reject.
It's when Coleman becomes for
Nathan a character,
the person becomes this living
representation,
that he is drawn out of his
solitude.
So, in a way,
it's not even Coleman the
person that draws him out,
but his world when he
encounters Coleman and his
story,
when he sees Coleman's body
during that dance as a cipher,
as the sign of all that you
can't know about the other
fellow.
When he sees that about
Coleman, that's when he comes
out of one productive state of
communing with the brilliant
dead and comes in to the world
of Coleman who will be
dead very,
very shortly.
So, on Monday next I will talk
about that relationship between
desire and the literary,
between persons and characters,
between life and novel.
Think about those things as you
read.